this video is sponsored by North Vee P n
is there a more iconic moment in my view
this might be the single most important
scene in the history of Dragon Ball and
maybe even all of anime in the West but
something you might find interesting is
that there's more than one version of
this scene out there in fact there are
hundreds covering many different
languages across the globe today I want
to take a look at and review four
different versions of this scene in
order to figure out which is the one
true legendary scene in your eyes going
in order of release
I will first take a look at the original
manga chapter from 1991 the original
Japanese broadcast from the same year
followed by the English Funimation edit
and dubbed from 1999 capping it all off
with Dragon Ball Z Kai's redubbed
versions from the year 2010 but here's
the interesting part I want you to vote
for your favorite right now go for it
click one of the four options in the top
right because at the end of this video I
want you to vote again it'll be the
exact same poll and I want to see if
this video made you change your mind or
if it reinforced your current pick and
so with that explained let's get this
show rolling with the very first time
this legendary scene hit the public eye
and to do that we need to go all the way
back to the streets of Japan on March 19
1991 titled life or death this was
written and drawn entirely by Akira
Toriyama the chapter itself is 17 pages
long which is longer than the typical
chapter back then so let's see how the
manga the original source of the story
has the events unfold it opens as Gohan
and Quinn look on at the massive crater
created by the spirit bomb scanning for
any signs of life
Gohan notices piccolo dragging both
himself and a barely conscious Goku out
of the oceans rapid current something of
interest is that piccolo is supposed to
have three fingers and a thumb in the
manga but in this panel he has four
fingers and a thumb small mistake using
what little energy they have left go on
and krillen fly towards them they
celebrate and embrace one another until
a dreaded expression falls over Cullen's
face goku asks what is a Crillon eye
only for God we left Bouma Goku breathes
a sigh of relief and together they share
a laugh even piccolo reflects at how
dynamic and its people have suffered
until Frieza has survived standing atop
a rocky pillar immediately fires a death
beam right through Piccolo's chest he
collapses to the floor
piccolo goku glares at Frieza who says
even I thought I was dead I nearly was
immediately Goku instructs Gohan and
krillen to take piccolo and Bulma to the
ship and leave Curlin is confused with
this decision but Goku screams for him
to do as he says in order to protect his
life do you really think I'll let them
go not one of you are leaving here alive
I am still more than a match for all of
you
[Music]
[Laughter]
stop it Frieza who's next the brat
you're not gonna get away with this
I just won't let you
what's interesting about this moment is
that there's no screen it's very much
something inside Goku snapping one
moment his hair is black and the other
suing the same position
the legendary energy of the Super Saiyan
is flowing through him as Frieza looks
on stunned into silence
Goku aggressively instructs Gohan to get
into the ship with everyone and leave
Gohan hesitates causing Goku to exclaim
Gohan get out of here while I still have
some control over myself with that Gohan
moves to leave the last panel a super
safe staring at his target this chapter
features a ton of iconic panels that I'm
sure many of you are already familiar
with however now that we understand the
source material let's take a look at the
first interpretation the original
Japanese broadcast original release June
12th
first things first let's talk filler
around this point in time in the anime
the manga was only about three months
ahead of the actual series which
resulted in a large amount of filler and
this episode is no different
fun fact it's actually this filler and
stalling for time that turn freezes five
minutes until the planets destruction
into the meme that it is today within
this particular episode 5 minutes or 25%
of the total run time is dedicated to a
subplot on King Kai's planet surrounding
the Z warriors and astonishingly the
ginyu force we're in the ginyu force
basically show up and then get
subsequently kicked off very quickly it
serves no real purpose other than to
stall for time and to confuse the
viewers more the rest of the episode is
pretty much the single chapter of the
manga that we covered earlier and it's
pretty stretched out prior to piccolo
surfacing with Goku go on and krillen
discuss what might happen now this isn't
a major issue but the episode is full of
filler dialogue that serves no greater
purpose other than to pad the runtime
for example in addition to Crillon
remembering that he had vomitorium out
he mentions that he wants to get married
you know stuff of that nature ultimately
harmless but serves no greater purpose
however as the pleasantries conclude the
pace quickly changes for the better and
the tone darkness
[Music]
this scene in motion is tragic in the
most spectacular of ways the manga
panels have been brought to life and in
doing so injects so much more emotion to
the scene however there are some major
differences between this and the mangas
tell in the manga the panels appear in
this order Frieza takes aim piccolo is
shot he falls into the group and onto
the floor in the anime Frieza takes
aimed specifically at Goku piccolo
shoves him out of the way and takes the
shock to the chest for Goku this paints
a very different picture to what the
manga was going for is it better is it
worse let me know down below moving on
from that during Goku's transformation
the fashion within which he changes is
different also instead of it being a
sudden angry snapping there's a ton of
screaming
honestly from a cinematic perspective I
think this works tremendously well the
lightning the angles the emotion it's an
incredible scene
next up the Funimation dub but Before we
jump ahead to that I want to quickly
thank today's sponsor Nord VPN as many
of you know article 13 has passed in
Europe but fear not I have a solution
Nord VPNs encryption for your IP and
data protection if you use Nord VPN
service article 13 can tell that you're
from Europe I use it personally and it's
as simple as that if you're interested
or want to support the channel follow
the link in the description Nord VPN
comm 4/2 lean up mark and use the coupon
code
totally not mark to get 75% off and
protect yourself for three years $2.99
per month while getting an extra month
completely free
protect yourself adore VPNs
military-grade encryption enable it on
your Android and iOS devices and my
personal favorite never worry about
region locks again go to Nord VPN comm
4/2 lean up mark and use coupon code
kollene up mark to protect yourself
online today and so with that covered
let's look at how the early Funimation
dub measures up original release October
18 1999 over eight years after the
original air date in Japan folks in the
West finally got an English dub of this
scene titled transformed at last the
interpretation of events is identical to
the original Japanese version visually
though it might be cropped depending on
what release you have of this that said
there are a host of differences from a
dialog perspective so let's dive in I
won't touch on every single inaccuracy
but I'll point out some of the bigger
ones starting with this scene as Gohan
and krillen look on after the Spirit
Bomb for any signs of life in the manga
Gohan can sense piccolo or Goku because
his key is too low to utilize that power
what I will play now is the exact same
sentence from both the Japanese dub and
the English Funimation dub
beautiful I didn't go to that that's
because you're not concentrating hard
enough on it go on this creates a
strange dynamic within the story of this
episode for an important reason
it insinuates that Crillon consensus
father in piccolo which means that
Crillon can sense energy regardless of
how tardy is implying that Goku and
piccolo should be able to do the same
which begs the question why didn't they
sense Frieza in the manga and Japanese
dub it's established that because they
are all low on energy they can sense the
energy of others and thus it makes sense
how Frieza could get the drop on them in
this version additionally once Frieza
does appear the manner with which Goku
orders Gohan and krillen to leave in the
Japanese dub is much more aggressive
than in the English Funimation dub where
he sounds more like a scolding father
for example in the Japanese he says get
the hell out of here you guys are in my
way do you all want to die together here
in the English he says listen Gohan you
have to get out of here now you don't
have a say in the matter and finally
once Crillon has been brutally killed by
Frieza instead of threatening Gohan's
life Frieza says la blows ELISA in
addition to all of this the
aforementioned filler with the ginyu
force on King Kai's planet is also still
present in this version however the
biggest difference between this version
and other versions that must be the
Bruce Faulconer score where in the
Japanese version prior had the Kikuchi
score this score completely reinvented
the tone of Dragon Ball for many in the
West
and now finally let's jump ahead to our
final version Dragon Ball Kai original
release March 7th and November 27th 2010
entitled awake legendary warriors son
Goku the super saiyan this episode was
redubbed and released on March 7th 2010
in Japan and November 27th 2010 for
english-speaking audiences the driving
forces behind the Dragon Ball Kai read
up of the series was to essentially have
a recut streamlined version of the
original run of the Dragon Ball anime
aiming to cut out much of the filler
portions where possible and within this
particular section the filler was
completely removed so that means no more
confusing ginyu for segments however in
order for this to reach the runtime of
an entire episode it begins before Goku
throws the spirit bomb the dialogue in
the Japanese version is just as faithful
and accurate as it initially was in the
broadcast from the 90s so let's take a
closer look and focus on the English dub
of the scene the inaccuracies that were
present in the early Funimation dub have
been brought more in line with the
original mangas version for example
while Quillin said this in the
Funimation dub that's because you're not
concentrating hard enough on it Gohan
well of course you can't it's not like
you have any energy left to concentrate
with and finally instead of saying pop
goes the weasel in response to cruel ins
death Frieza says I think the brat
should go needs and so before I give you
guys the chance to vote again here are
the Super Saiyan screams from all the
different versions
[Music]
and so this is where things get really
interesting now that I have broken down
the original manga chapter from 1991 the
original Japanese broadcast from the
same year the Funimation dub from 1999
and the Dragon Ball Kai version of the
series from 2010 I would like to present
you with the opportunity to cast your
vote a second time click here and let us
know which interpretation of the events
outlined do you think presented at best
did your opinion change or did it stay
the same let me know in the comments
down below
I'm really interested to see the results
of this video if you would like to see
more videos like this one subscribe I
upload every Thursday and don't forget
to leave a like or dislike on the video
thank you so much for watching and I'll
see you guys next week
[Applause]
[Music]